in Psychology the dark Triad represents  three personality traits narcissism  psychopathy and machiavellianism people  scoring high on the three traits are  more likely to commit crimes and create  severe social problems in society  families and organizations  if we were to ask the three who has the  darkest personality The Narcissist would  say me the psychopath would say I don't  care and the Machiavellian would say  it's whoever I wanted to be  if your mind was programmed to be  impulsive aggressive and selfish you are  also more likely to abuse drugs feel  excluded suffer from depression or end  up in jail  foreign